hello freak [ __ ] how do they know
that how do they know that our source
today
how do they know that our sources say
negative things about the guys we don't
like well you were talking about Tiger
Woods on your podcast I was listening to
on the way over here and I totally agree
with you
we sound like when Tigers world fell
apart like how the [ __ ] do you know like
woody did you talk to him like you don't
know him yeah didn't have a conversation
it was a brutal couple of years but it
was 10 years ago yeah in in 10 years he
hasn't [ __ ] up
other than this DUI so I mean yeah he
[ __ ] up but hey you know yeah I guess
about you why didn't 89 so I'm gonna
judge him right the DUI apparently he's
on some back medication that's what it
is he mixed his medication that's what
he's saying but they said he smelled
like booze but I don't know I should
just take the hit yeah you know I [ __ ]
up I banged the tellers and blah blah
blah I'm not good and I'm not
controlling what the guy did but I'm not
gonna sit there and judge the guy and be
like I was watching some guy and he was
trying to say that you know you know he
let us down he sold himself as a family
man it's like you built that whole
[ __ ] narrative yeah you built that
whole now I just watched him play golf
all I ever want to do when I watch golf
is watch those guys [ __ ] crush it
like for I love John Daly I love that
he's like [ __ ] you I like drinking he
just kept drinking who's smoking
cigarette cigarettes
baguette and he would hit it a [ __ ]
mile and I love an election it well
Tiger always had a very bizarre style
apparently I don't play golf but
apparently people that I've talked to
that explained to me the way you would
hit the ball like it's not the way they
teach you to do it but he could do it so
well that way but he put like ridiculous
amounts of torque yes on his ball on his
body they said from the beginning that
his body was going to break down if he
keeps doing that there was a period
where he adjusted his swing and he
stopped he stopped winning then he came
back again and I just think that what
they said there was a bunch of guys Earl
Campbell they said if he keeps running
like that he's wide open he's going to
have problems Bobby Orr the way he
played hockey which you throw yourself
around he really beat the [ __ ] out of
your body like that happens and it just
coincided with his personal life falling
art so everybody goes oh that's the
reason why you know somebody wins that's
the reason why somebody loses like look
I'm not saying you don't go to a couple
years if you yeah your life falls apart
in a parcel layer but it's just like the
rest of that [ __ ] you know that was I
mean that's just a bunch of hype like
for him it's like a double dump though
you know I mean the thing happens
personally with his personal life and it
happens publicly where everybody gets to
see it and on top of that his body's
falling apart of the same huh no matter
what yes yeah no matter we went to
church every [ __ ] week he was going
to [ __ ] up his back in his knees and
they'd and it did but then they're
trying to equate it to you know whatever
though I think what he did was none of
my business it's none of my [ __ ]
business I don't want to know about it I
hate knowing about you know I feel bad
if somebody I if their marriage falls
apart so bad they get busted for job you
know I mean it happens if you [ __ ] up
and it's your fault you should get
punched but like the cops are handling
it they arrested him the courts will
handle it do I need to talk to I need a
pylon and start wagging my [ __ ]
hypocrite and a finger Adam my YC
freckled you don't have to because
you're a comedian and you're funny and
your take on things can be have some
compassion look at it for what it is
make fun poke at it but when you're one
of those [ __ ] straight-up Sports
commentator guys you don't have a whole
lot of wiggle room as far as what you
could say what you don't say and you got
to go right down the middle and attack
you've got to go to the polls yeah go
Disney yeah I mean what does it say
about the fabric what about a zephyr of
our community you know the morals of our
kind this creates a culture look at this
Tiger Woods is lost in every literal and
figurative way by Ian O'Connor yes PN
sport 14 okay
Tiger Woods you met in Jupiter Florida
police report is not the tyre Woods
presented to you by Tiger his sponsors
and his reps fat woods thing is I think
what this is [ __ ] ESPN those guys on
TV what they present is not who the [ __ ]
they are yeah look at this I mean this
is so ridiculous they're saying that
Woods is a new and improved human being
since extramarital sex scandal from hell
a better father and friend with or
without a golfer like how do you [ __ ]
know you have sympathy for the guy who
wrote this to the giotto he has to write
it you know Connor has to sit down and
they got Jay
is Christ how am I going to keep being a
senior writer unless I act like this
[ __ ] actually bothers me you have to
write something inflammatory you have to
write something salacious you gotta you
got to get people to click you have to
get a lot of clickbait
[Applause]
[Music]